from the united kingdom ksi has crowned
the winner in ksi versus Logan Paul to
the YouTube sensations were back in the
ring for another boxing match on
Saturday
this time on Logan Paul's home turf at
the steeple Center in LA with a handful
of celebrities like French Montana Chris
Brown Justin Bieber and Logan's brother
Jake Paul in attendance Jake's not
exactly legal bride Tana mojo was also
there
but she wasn't by his side during the
fight oh and according to an eyewitness
Wiz Khalifa had fans flocking towards
him when he showed up but when they
tried to get his attention the rapper
reportedly pretended to smoke a blonde
but back to the match the online stars
threw down a scrappy dogfight each
fighter throwing a flurry of punches in
the first three rounds of the six round
match quickly wearing themselves down
the last two rounds are going to be
hellacious for him because he won't have
[Applause]
Jackie says let's go loca Paul may be
hurt
Paul threw an uppercut that connected in
round four almost ending the fight
but both men came alive in the final
round
couple clubbing blows who can decide who
seems to have found his second wind here
both trying to land some hits and do
damage in their final minutes of battle
in the end it came down to a split
decision
I think nine out of ten times I being a
BJJ
tonight was the night that one out of
ten times you can hear my voice I'm sick
I woke up sick I've been sick for the
past three days ksi and Paul first went
head to head in August 2008 team at the
Manchester Arena in the UK in what was
called the biggest internet event in
history the match ended in a majority
draw making a rematch inevitable Plus
both YouTube stars signed a to fight
agreement even before the first one went
down earlier this week Paul opened up to
et about how boxing turned his life
around the narrative for the first fight
was chaos I saved my career and in you
know I don't know if that's true
a hundred percent but there's like some
merit in that like he definitely helped
me come out of the the trench I was in
post Tokyo and in exchange ya ksi has
now become like a global name both
youtubers took to Instagram ahead of
Saturday's fights Paul posting this
photo with the caption tonight my life
begins and ksi sharing a shot of the two
of them and writing time to end
Logan's career tomorrow what do you
really think of him fight the 26 year
old Brit instagrammed this snap
captioning it let's go champ
turns out ksi with the crown pick before
the punches even started flying and when
the fight was over it was Justin Bieber
who ran into the ring to calm
Logan's temper if I were JJ I would not
take the third fight I he he got that W
today like leave while you can it is not
safe I'm confident nine out of ten times
I beat this guy today was not my day
someone to take a fight that makes sense
and I'm always pushing the boundaries
with everything that I do so if there's
something that you know makes me want to
push the boundary some more than yeah
I'll do it
[Music]